one of the areas I'm really interested
in is getting groups of people to work
together in a flow state a common place
where you forget time that is fun
interesting and highly productive now
when I was in seventh grade walked into
the band room wanting to learn music
they handed me because they had braces a
tuba and said this is what you're gonna
play okay great and I started learning
how to play with others I started
playing in jazz bands and wind ensembles
and so what I started feeling is that I
was an important part along with others
in producing a song that none of us by
ourselves could play and so this common
goal of working together was produced by
a musical experience and so that's kind
of how I look at that flow state if you
actually I'm on the board of Berklee
College of Music which is a great music
school contemporary music but it does a
lot in jazz so imagine you're in a jazz
band and the great skills and the jazz
band are to be won a great player got it
but to to have a managed ego so that you
put aside yourself and listen to the
other great performers as well and then
you will start innovating you'll start
jamming with them based on what they do
and what they say so how they perform
and the music sound that comes out of it
is unique in something different than
you could have ever done by yourself
we're all in flow state at one shape or
form sometime you've experienced it
sports figures experience it on the
field where they describe things as
opening up field opens you can six
perience that when I was an old computer
science guy when I was working on a
computer program all sudden I woke up
four hours later have to having done a
lot and kind of lost sense of time
that's what a flow state is
it tends to there's a lot of skills and
tools a lot of tools you can use to get
into a flow state more frequently we've
done research at Yale using fMRI is to
analyze what goes on in the brain and
you can see when people are in a present
state more frequently using
contemplative skills so the skills of
mindfulness meditation contemplation you
can get there with yoga you can get
there lots of different angles your
training your mind and we're actually
seeing neurons neuronal paths change in
the mind that's through the FMR eyes
this is the University of Wisconsin this
is through Harvard research and so how
can you get individuals to experience
this flow state by going into deeper
contemplation being quiet the average
number of thoughts that go through your
mind you can actually allocate them out
and a lot of different studies have gone
through it and 70% of them on average or
about the past 20% of those thoughts are
about the future 10% are about now so
what if you can make that 10% larger and
that's really what flow States about is
dropping those thoughts you know how do
you drop thoughts I don't know how to do
that well by being quiet and letting
those thoughts just happen but letting
them go there's lots of tools and
techniques for doing that and go online
and check out headspace calm it's one of
companies that you can go on and for
free they'll teach you about meditation
or do yoga or do Tai Chi or just be
quiet or go to your church and pray
those are all states of contemplation
and you're training your mind and your
pads and your mind are changing and now
there's devices coming that will allow
you to feel it so this experience that I
felt and music you say ah I want to do
that again and then you can see it in
your brain there's what actually one
company called inter axon you put this
device on your head a headband and it
will measure brainwaves and through
Bluetooth access computer programs that
allow you to train your brain and saying
oh that's what it feels like to be more
accurate
you can play to increase the mortar make
it more likely that you'll be in a
present state and so what if we did that
for ADHD they're working on it so right
now they can identify the brainwaves
that identify ADHD the FDA just to prove
that so now a lot of people were working
on what if we get biofeedback so that
children and adults don't need the drugs
that they're currently are taking for
ADHD it's a huge application think of
how more effective people will be if
they're able to train their own minds if
you want to go sleep more quickly do
that so think out more efficient any
team was from companies to nonprofits to
collaborations if individuals take
ownership of their own thoughts and
become more present and we're in flow
state more frequently
we're all gonna be more
you